(music playing)
One of the most common questions
we get about Android Performance
is about using enums in your code.
I mean, this question pops up
literally everywhere--
on Stack Overflow,
on our Q&A after our talks,
and even during casual lunches
at the local food court.
Anyhow, my name is Colt McAnlis,
and enums in your Android apps
are both tricky and not so tricky,
which is why there's some confusion.
But a little history here.
So back in 2009 there was a web page
on developers.android.com that said to
avoid using enums for performance reasons.
But then it mysteriously
disappeared for a while
without really much explanation.
And then, of course, it came back later,
but in a much smaller state.
So what's the story here?
Well, the truth is a little bit nuanced
and has everything to do
with the difference between performance
and memory bloat.
See, when your app is loaded,
Android will set aside
a section of system memory
just for your app.
And in order for your app to run,
all of the DEX code for it
is loaded into that subspace.
But, of course,
this is ultimately shared with the rest
of the heap for any runtime allocations
that your app will make.
Thankfully, though, this doesn't contend
with your runtime allocations.
However, it does put more
pressure on the system memory,
which, of course, when memory gets low,
could cause your app to get terminated
to free up space.
So with that in mind, let's take a look at
the effect of enums on your application.
Let's say we have a small base app here,
whose entire DEX footprint is 2,556 bytes.
To this we add some integers
that represent states that can be used
and returned for our system.
After recompilation, the final DEX size
is 2,680 bytes,
meaning that these integers
in terms of code size,
have added an extra 124 bytes
to our base executable.
Now, for comparison,
let's take the same base application,
but implement it with enums
instead of integers.
The result here
is a DEX file of 4,188 bytes.
So, adding a single enum to this code
has added an extra 1,632 bytes
to the final DEX size, or for those of you
who are super fancy with math,
about 13x more memory
than the INT version.
This, of course, bloats your DEX file,
which eats away at your heap space.
If this isn't bad enough, though,
there's also the runtime memory overhead
to be concerned with as well.
In general, each enum value declaration
will cost you about 20 plus bytes.
Of course, plus there's the object array
needed to keep track of the enum value,
so that's another 12 bytes
for that header as well.
Well, it's 16 on Dalvik, by the way.
Anyhow, this extra overhead is taken
by each enum declared in your code,
meaning that the more enums in your app,
the more space will be eaten up.
And this whole thing can get out of hand
easier than you might think.
For example, if enums
are widely used across your application,
or if they're inside of a library
that's used by many applications
on the device,
all of those small pieces of overhead
quickly add up to a substantial amount.
And the worst part is
that you don't really know
that enums are causing a problem
until they're already infecting
your code base.
And by that point, trying to fix it
is really a horrible process.
Think of it this way-- enums are
kind of like gremlins, right?
I mean, one or two by themselves,
not really a big deal.
You could take them out
with a rolled-up newspaper
or a baseball bat or a flamethrower
if you've got one of those laying around.
But when you get a whole
bunch of them together,
trouble really happens there,
and you wish you had the flamethrower.
That's why the Core Platform Team,
the folks who write the Android code,
have a strong recommendation
to avoid using enums
in any part of the code they write.
This allows them to be proactive
about the potential problems here
rather than being reactive.
With that in mind, here's a couple things
that you should consider
to address the problem.
Firstly, if you're using INTs for values
instead of enums,
you can add @IntDef annotation to them,
which will give your code built time safety,
when Lint errors are enabled,
while still retaining the size
and performance benefits
of using INT variables.
Basically, this allows you
to get the best of both worlds.
And secondly, if your code
is set up the right way,
Proguard can, in many situations,
optimize enums to INT values
on your behalf, so you really
don't need to think about it
or do any work,
which is one of the few places
that you might get
performance wins for free.
Most of the time you have to fight for it.
Which is why you should check out the rest
of the Android Performance Patterns videos
and stop by to ask some questions
at our Google+ Community, as well.
Because you're not alone.
So keep calm, profile your-- oh, my god!
(gremlin noises)
(music playing)